A wise crack jared irl,
again,
for those pumping in for the first time,
this is still an experiment where we
quickly respond to developments in TV
and film as they happen,
not just rick and Morty,
so if you like them or have a request,
let us know the indicators.
Three return of the world enter was a
pretty awesome job at marvel.
Movies with the vindicator is acting as
an obvious stand in for the avengers and
rick acting as a mouthpiece for people
disillusioned with the rather formulaic
state of popular cinema or the writers
have their own press releases.
Morning,
there are a bunch of drama queens and
spend an hour talking at 20 minutes.
Jumping around.
We'll ship blows up there.
A phase.
We did one,
it was the big event at at summer,
let it die,
but instead of focusing on Rick's beef
with our Disney overlords,
we're going to set our sights a little
higher today.
Superhero films have been clumsy,
grasping with the concepts of good
knievel for what seems like an eternity,
and this episode of Rick and morty
comments on this and some pretty clever
and even profound ways working on this
wise crack.
Quick take on vindicator three,
the return over the world,
and you guessed it,
spoilers.
First,
a recap or he gets to choose the next
adventure with Rick,
so he decides to spend it with his
heroes.
The indicators in good Sanchez,
he and fashion rick gets blackout drunk,
destroys the ominous world under with
little effort and traps the indicators
in a series of trials that ruins them.
The real art of indicators.
Three,
like another morty adventure we know is
more these optimistic worldview
crumbling around him.
In the case of me and destroy mortise
wholesome view of fairytales erodes as
the genre is subverted.
In this episode,
mortise faith in the indicators are
roads as the superhero genre is a
burden,
but beneath all the vendors and
superhero jokes.
So your origin is what you fell into a
vat of redundancy.
This episode is also about the
complexities of good and evil.
I'd like some adventures where mortise
view of the world is shattered.
Rick plays a unique role in making his
worldview.
You disintegrate here after killing
world under while blackout drunk,
rick creates a saw inspired puzzle that
is less a thought out plan to make
people confront their demons,
all La Jigsaw and more a drunk and
scheme to push people over a moral cliff
and it works.
Vance shows his true colors.
You're the learning disabled kid.
New Photo APP,
Dwayne.
Okay,
but this is triggering me.
I need space.
I need space from a million ants,
kills Alan rails over.
A woman and crocky bought.
Brings out the indicators.
Little secret.
What happened on Dorian five?
Nothing.
We exterminated up planted by the end.
Rick gets to Lord over morty about the
sham.
That is heroism.
I appreciate it.
Marty.
I know you were sucking the Koolaid out
of the indicators,
so the fact that I was right about that
must be pretty hard to admit.
Yeah,
it is.
What's really clever about this episode
is how they draw from some of the more
unique villains and popular cinema.
Brick is,
is this a saw thing?
Are you seriously sodding the
syndicators 40.
I'm a drunk,
not a hack.
Unlike most antagonistic jigsaw isn't
about senseless murder or financial
game.
He wants to change people's paradigms by
making them endorse suffering in some
cases to make them appreciate life more.
Similarly drunk.
Rick's trials aren't meant primarily to
eradicate the indicators,
but rather to create a moral crisis for
them approving to morty that they are
not heroes.
Every one in the universe is a hero.
Mom,
which is why we don't need jackets and
I'm pretty sure we don't need
vindicator.
Now.
I thought this was pretty cool in
itself,
but what I thought really elevated this
episode was a less obvious inspiration.
The joker mortise trip in the carnival
ride seems inspired by Alan Moore's,
the killing joke.
When Commissioner Gordon is tortured by
the joker like Jigsaw,
the joker isn't only motivated by
murder.
He's out to prove that with one
sufficiently bad day or could become
just as mad as him as another joker.
Inspired by the killing joke puts it.
See Madness,
as you know,
is like gravity.
All it takes is a little push and what
is Rick's shenanigans in this episode,
but to push the vindicator to lose,
they're just,
as the joker infects the once idealistic
harvey with his nihilistic philosophy by
killing Rachel and turning corrupt cops
against him.
So too does rick turn the benevolent
indicators into violent backstabbers?
Thus appending morty simplistic
understanding of good and evil.
Oh,
I dunno.
You managed to destroyed just about
everything today.
The villains,
the heroes,
the lines between them.
My childhood.
Thank you.
Okay,
so rick doesn't really buy that.
Heroes are good,
but there's a larger point about how the
way were spoonfed narratives of good and
evil is actually super bad.
You know,
narratives like this one,
everyone in the universe is a hero.
All you have to do is know the
difference between good and bad and root
for good,
but thinking in such simple terms can
lead to problems.
For philosopher Jacques Ron Sierra,
the problem with evil,
with a big capital eat,
you know the kind in every single
superhero movie is there any kind of
conflict becomes the ultimate struggle
of good and evil.
The value of winning that battle becomes
well,
infinite.
It's a fight for the soul of the world
or galaxy or universe,
all or nothing,
so people can do even be worse in the
world to achieve victory,
but as the logic goes,
isn't a justified what's so bad about
letting a few thousand people die if it
means destroying ultimate evil?
Well,
oh,
what happened on Dorian five?
Nothing.
We exterminated a planet.
Wait,
huh?
Do Nama?
Tron was hiding there.
He's a shape shifter.
Destroying Dorian five was the only way
to kill him.
I could have made you a device to
detect.
Do Nama metronic from orbit like that.
What does this say about the
syndicators?
To summarize the problem with infinite
evil,
whether in the form of world destroyers
or mortal humans is they weren't
infinite justice.
The kind that doesn't really care about
morals or people of Dorian five and
often even loses sight of the justice
part by the end of the episode,
Supernova has also been infected with
Rick's nihilistic philosophy no longer
believing in a real division between
good and evil.
However,
she recognizes the simplistic division
must be upheld.
It's like you said,
there's no right or wrong.
I never said that.
The galaxies faith in the vindicator
that keeps the galaxy secure.
She's willing to kill Rick and Morty and
even her lover to protect the perception
that the indicators are good.
It's not their actions that matter.
It's the galaxies faith in their
actions.
That does.
I'm pretty sure.
This is another shout out to the dark
knight,
which is probably the best example of
moral grayness in a comic book movie
where Batman lies about the goodness of
Harvey Dent to maintain peace in order
in Gotham,
supernova wants the galaxy to believe in
a similar lie about herself.
In both cases,
people are advocating for a noble lie.
The idea that societies can be built on
a myth that maintains order.
An idea made famous by the Greek
philosopher Plato and it's not the first
time rick and morty has made this kind
of dark.
Knight asked Noble Lie,
shout out.
We found it inside a lockbox box.
Inside King Jellybeans closet.
We have to tell the people,
wait,
destroy it,
or people will get more from the idea.
He represented from the Jelly Bean,
he actually was.
Now,
this is kind of philosophy 101,
but it's worth noting at least because
of its relation to the dark knight,
but where the dark knight kind of
celebrates the slide.
Rick and morty uses it to deconstruct
the myths of superheroes.
Rick says good and bad are artificial
constructs.
Yeah,
well,
I get the feeling he kind of needs that
to be the case.
However,
rather than just deconstructing good and
evil as arbitrary concepts,
which by the way it's done before.
I mean seriously,
I may be the devil,
but your grandpa is the devil.
Show was also suggesting that the
complete absence of these concepts isn't
so great either.
This is a clever call back to the last
episode where Dr Wong Confronts Rick in
saying,
only connection between your
unquestionable intelligence and the
sickness destroying your family is that
everyone in your family,
you've included use intelligence to
justify sickness.
Whereas the vindicator fail to
critically engaged with their methods or
even their mission.
Rick refuses to engage with his
decisions for the exact opposite reason
because nothing matters,
and if nothing matters and good and evil
or just social constructs,
then he can't consider his actions evil.
You can just continue doing whatever he
wants,
so the episode presents us with to
differing perspectives regarding good
knievel,
both of which are in typical rick and
morty fashion,
completely dismal.
We either have zero conviction of the
division between good and evil,
which leads rick to doing whatever he
wants and it not mattering,
or we have complete and utter conviction
of what constitutes good and evil and
people end up doing really messed up for
the sake of good,
like blow up an entire planet.
As always,
in Rick and Morty,
there are no right answers,
only wrong ones.
If you want to hear more depressing rick
and morty philosophy,
check out our rick and morty podcasts,
the squash.
We're breaking down every episode in
detail,
answering your questions and you'll even
get to hear the joker impression I've
been working on for nearly a decade.
It's getting there.
Click on the link below or subscribe
wherever you get your podcasts.
Stay good.
Wisecrack piece.